the star of the movie Chuck based on the
life of Chuck Wepner is Liam Schreiber
who joins us of course ray Donovan
director writer producer what did you
think when you got the invitation of
what this show this show you're on right
now was all about I I did to be honest I
I'm I don't really follow sports that
much yeah but I last night at work all
the guys were very excited that I was
coming so you feel a little better I
felt well I was actually made me a
little nervous I thought wow this is a
bigger deal than I thought it was oh so
you thought there's gonna be hardcore
sports I actually thought this was gonna
be a radio interview oh you did yeah you
didn't realize it was TV no I didn't
know that sure they would see Mike but
the cameras here just for show
don't worry about that and don't don't
worry about them uh but I love I love
this story of Chuck Wepner but I'm
familiar with it because I remember when
he fought and you can kind of brief
people on Chuck Wepner why you loved
what Chuck Wepner stood for since he was
an OK boxer but his his uh like regular
life was what was fascinating to me so
what drew you to this role well one of
the sports that I do follow is boxing
and I was sort of surprised that I
hadn't heard his story I didn't know who
he was particularly when I found out
that he was in the inspiration for Rocky
um but he was a he was ranked in the top
eight at one point uh he had fought in
some incredible guys he thought Sonny
Liston he fought Ernie Terrell he fought
George Foreman pretty impressive list of
heavyweights that he went up against and
in 1975 he fought Muhammad Ali and was
it like a 40 to 100 dog who's just some
hilarious footage I saw Marv Albert
interviewing people in Cincinnati and
they're all saying they want their money
back who's this guy and you know he
doesn't deserve this is right after Ali
fought us right after Ali fought
Foreman's I hear and everybody thinks
he's a second coming which he was so so
people were just convinced he's gonna
get knocked out in the first three
rounds and it's an extraordinary fight
because sort of like the film
about the ninth round the whole crowd in
this Cincinnati Coliseum is chanting
Chuck's name just that he's staying on
his feet just to be surviving this this
punishment but he's just a real tough
heavyweight who later on in life
kind of was living in the shadow of the
Rocky movie and didn't handle it all
that well he sued Sylvester Stallone
didn't he because if you look at Rocky
and some of the names that are used in
Rocky you don't have to you know there's
no gray area there it looks like that
it's all based off Chuck Wepner yeah i'm
i think they said a lot of court on that
and everybody's okay now but did you
meet chuck when you were doing yeah i
did yoga Naomi and I took Chuck and
Linda his wife to see the golovkin fight
at the garden oh yeah but he said he had
over 300 stitches
I think he's broken his nose a couple of
times if you watch the five times I
think seven times yeah but he he was
sort of leaning on Ollie you know later
in that fight like he was holding on for
dear life oh yeah but everybody kept
saying well how come Ollie can't put him
away then he became this sort of
underdog cold hero that the Bayonne
bleeder which is not a great name for a
boxer I get to testament to his heart
and his courage you know I think
Stallone did a great job in the movie I
think with that aspect of Chuck's life
how do you make boxing seems realistic
ah it's my problem with boxing movies is
that you know even in even Rocky is to
the boxing looks so fake I got I guess
because the the essential premise of
going to a fight is that you're going to
see somebody get punched in the face and
when that doesn't happen it feels kind
of fraudulent a pooch hole who does a
really great job and plays Muhammad Ali
in the film and I are sparring partners
in real life with Baca we trained
together and so we had we had a couple
of fighters on ray Donovan professional
fighters doing some background work for
us and I was watching these guys and
because they're so good and so familiar
with each other they were making contact
without hurting each other they knew the
choreography so they're actually hitting
each other and you can see the sweat
flying off their heads and I was like
well that actually
was like fighting so pooch and I
rehearsed the choreography for a couple
weeks and and I got hit a lot because
that's sort of would happen in the fight
did you get like really hit I think it
it never would pooch no but there was a
Bulgarian fighter because we had to
shoot the fights in in Sofia whoo-hoo I
there was something lost in translation
telling the Bulgarian fighter that he
was allowed to hit me you're supposed to
be off-limits you're the storm yeah
that's what I say I mean off-limits for
the really hard sham you know who should
hit me in the Farhad you know probably
like eight hundred and thirty times
Phillipe says which was just just to get
the wig moving in the sweat popping off
my head but this Bulgarian guy I could
just see it in his eyes when they said
you can hit him but you can't hit him
but he had no idea what they were
talking about mustache looked good thank
you thank you
Chuck gave me a lot of grief about it
actually was that a real one yeah you
know no I grew that mustache it was
actually the only hair that I had during
that photos well no I had sideburns too
which which was really horrible because
I'd shaved my head to be bold under a
wig but later on a really good hair
person said I didn't need to do that
that's tough advice to get after you've
shaved your head yeah because I you know
what I'd go out I had to wear a hat all
the time because I literally I had I
don't know I wish I had a picture of it
but I had I had sideburns can we put
that up do we have a picture on the on
mustache and then shaved head and it was
it was pretty horrible I lived like that
for about two months and but when you're
done with something like it are you
still in it's just the picture there
with oh yeah that's like you see there's
a wig there but underneath that wig is a
shaved head the only thing that's real
in that picture is the mustache and the
sideburns imagine if you pulled that
really really attractive wig off my head
but those are the those are the chains
you wear in real life though no no no
yet no lo see of course those are nice
and Jim Gaffigan is in the movie that's
the Michael Rapaport is in this great
great great great supporting cast
Elizabeth moss is just extraordinary can
you can you
for another segment here I want to ask
you about hard knocks okay
I didn't realize for the longest time
that that was your voice neither did my
mother okay but but it's it's so
distinctive but I want to talk to you
about that because I thought we might
have a voice off here yeah I I thought
about that too as I was like as I was
listening to you yesterday yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay all right let's go yeah
right now and canoer
you go first you go okay could you
simulate a fight scene during the break
with one of my guys one of the Dennett's
do am I gonna get hit you can hit them
okay cool yeah all right we'll come back
with Liam Schreiber
right up to this the movie is Chuck in
select cities today nationwide next
Friday May 12th we're back after this in
the Dan Patrick show we're back it gives
me a very ko painting all right so yeah
so I'll look like one okay so you're
going to tell us how you orchestrated
this in the fight so how do you do most
of the time I just tie oh okay now what
do i do - Mikal you were supposed to
make that sound we practice airing this
okay so mop like this yeah yeah detector
so so so yeah relax you will well that
we can't really do that this preparation
because we want to relax your arms and I
just go that's it spot to the face but
you bring your hands oh yeah so what you
do is you act like you're grabbing your
face right yep so Paul you way to get
you okay
well not the cameras are over there so
there have to be this way okay okay why
so there's a wide looping hook okay oh
he's gonna have a shot at all there how
much how much can you get this is so
much fun we just like kids were out yeah
great holding closer always clap is not
that good though you gotta relax your
arms right we'll go slow
there hey no I like that that's it's
just a workshop yeah now hitting for
real
yeah we're wearing could you rather area
rather get hit in the face of the gut by
accident in a fight let's say you're in
a Biman face yeah yeah the face doesn't
hurt it doesn't no not till the next day
perfect
but the kidney will duh you know that
yeah the the solar plexus and really the
worst is the liver I don't know
we've seen that in the fight for you
know you see guys if they box I mean you
know how tough boxers are and you see
that they get hit right here yes iam
wince and go down to the mat yeah that's
a liver shot that's the worst
yeah guys practice that because our
clapping knows you make a sacrifice
cookie sanding it what does that mean
we're talking to Liev Schreiber's who is
playing the title role of Chuck also in
ray Donovan he's been in x-men Wolverine
spotlight salt the screen movies been a
boxer on and off for 18 years but this
is a biopic on a Chuck Wepner the former
heavyweight who went 15 rounds with
Muhammad Ali and is 10 years in the ring
Wepner endured two knockouts eight
broken noses 300 stitches toughest
fights though outside of the ring is
there going to be a sequel to goon there
is less of the enforcers I think really
yeah have you shot never shot it's done
oh it is yeah once it come out I thought
it had it had come out and maybe not
maybe Mel maybe it's only had it's only
come out in Canada maybe it's still on
its way out here you came out in Canada
and it's honestly it's on its way
oh it is okay okay that would have been
awkward if it gets of it that's the kind
of thing I should know when I go on a
television show promote myself I should
know the films that I'm in and when they
come out yeah I hear it's fantastic
though that's of course it is once it
gets here once it crosses the border
it's going to be great but when you look
at an enforcer and boxer an enforcer in
hockey and as opposed to a boxer yeah
what similarities at all
yes Anchorage and it was one of the
things I didn't Chuck - I don't know if
it's because they're Canadian or because
they're hockey players but enforcers are
some of the nicest people ever meet
there's a kind of there's a kind of
politeness and the sweetness
yeah I met a lot of these guys you know
getting ready for the film and it's
really it's sort of shocking how polite
they are and we you know for the hockey
show we did we put mics on guys
and you could hear them just before the
fight they would always kind of ask sort
of politely it's like you want to go yes
okay all right after the after the after
the whistle you know after they call a
penalty sure let's go okay what they
know that's their job yeah like I may
not that's right just like you that's
right but I have to fight you Probert
used to tell a story about how young
guys coming up in the league would ask
him Bob Probert yeah young guys coming
up in the league would would just you
know it was like a notch in their sticks
sorry not to a thought probe which
they'd come up them and they'd say
excuse me uh mr. Probert would you mind
give me would you mind giving me 20
seconds after the whistle not just magic
would Bob Probert beat on them for 20
seconds to show their coach if they were
willing to do anything for the team
would you have been an enforcer if you
played hockey I would have had to then
because I couldn't do much else you know
I can't skate I can't handle the puck
though yeah because there is and we're
getting rid of boxing the fighting part
of this in hockey mm-hmm is that good or
bad I'm not you know I it's hard it's a
tough one hey I don't know what the
research is on the concussions are the
concussions mostly from fighting or the
concussions mostly from falling impact
it I mean it's such to me I hate to say
it but to me it's always been a part of
the game and I and I it's just I know I
know it's arcane but I I still get
excited when it happened well you're an
enforcer and Ray Donovan now as well so
if you're looking at all these roles
that here you are fighter here you are a
goon and then here you are an enforcer
you're kind of being labeled here aren't
you is a tough guy yeah you like that
label I don't think it's a terribly but
we thought you were gonna be overly or
not me oh sorry yes may I say no no I'm
not a tough guy you're not at all not at
all but but people think you are but
that's good yeah you like that that's a
valuable thing to have people think
about you whether it's true does it keep
you out of fights because yes people yes
when's the last time you were in a fight
I Demong
[Laughter]
with you but you are we thought you were
going to be overly serious yeah I said
in introducing you said that I was a
boxer what didn't you I'm not going to
correct you I've never boxed in my life
I mean I trained by I think you're
invisible
okay but that's good makes a box access
fabulous thing to have out there about
you know but stay with it I'm trying to
help now you just blew your cover here
what's going on with you right so he's
sort of a boxer sort of a boxer let's
leave it alone now enforcer ray Donovan
but you're also with ray Donovan Jon
Voight is on john-boy was about yes yeah
could you take John Boyd right now now
yeah you could I think so but back in
the day a younger John Voight versus you
right now no way John's like kicks your
ass yeah big time apparently he was very
good that's what he seems kind of
serious to Eddie he's also a big strong
guy he's got big heavy hands like Chuck
yeah I mean if you look at Chuck
John tooted their fists like the size of
my head they're big guys you're also the
voice Hard Knocks the voice-over
announcer so how does somebody come to
you and say we're doing their show hard
knocks do you want to do it um you know
about 20 years ago I was fortunate
enough to meet Ross Wien Greenberg got
me into vo and it was one of the best
things that ever happened to me I I love
that aspect of my work I love the shows
that they do um
and the writing is really everything
that's you know I as well it's like when
you get someone who does that right it's
it's magic and I think sort of in the
great tradition of of jaundice Enda and
NFL Films they were writing this really
dramatic stuff that I think that kind of
juxtaposition of athleticism and poetry
is really fantastic and I lucked into a
show like that early in my career but do
people recognize your voice no no
because you don't sound the way you do
on hard knocks while I'm talking to you
so what happens when you get in that
voiceover booth I think it's probably
because I'm trying to rip off John
descendent because John percenter was
the voice of NFL Films for years and he
was just a news
and in Philadelphia but had this
unbelievable amazing well and do you
have a frosty fields of Minnesota the
Vikings made their finals that whole
thing was like I get chills every time I
remember it was the Redskins in the
Raiders and kill Theismann was the
quarterback so it was the silver and
black clad masters of intimidation
nearly took Joe Theismann's head off and
then it was the 1812 overture and I'm
going slow moly Haskell and the steam oh
they amazing that you're right they
created Povich violent poetry yeah yeah
what have you what else would be voiced
over anything odd I've done a lot of
Docs honestly I can never remember them
what I want to remember them but I must
have done around 200 bucks I think
probably my favorite and it changes from
time to time with that magic bird doc
did you meet them no no ever but when
you get something like that they give
you lines to read a script to read
absolutely do you need to see the video
do you need to kind of get more of the
fullness ons in the beginning when I
started I would watch it and then they
would sometimes play it in the booth for
me while I was doing it and over time I
got to the point where I found it was
distracting to watch oh really because
if you were reading the writers work
well you weren't actually paying
attention to picture and if the writing
was good you actually weren't paying
attended the picture you were you're
paying attention to the writing and you
can make good money as a voice-over guy
could you do like a movie like in a
world
oh yeah like well I do it in Chuck but
oh you mean like I'm like a movie
falling guy yeah yeah like you yeah yeah
you'd be the guy that does the movie
trailer yeah
that would ruin me forever it would
because then every time I did the sports
shows like oh no it's the movie phone
guy well we appreciate you stopping by
thanks for hand up you taught us now how
to act like we've taken a punch here you
look I hope you guys
Octus that eventually you could have
sort of a five-way melee in here yes
well a lot of fans emailing in saying
they're disappointed we have didn't
really dec me they really wanted me to
go down hard you wouldn't I can't
illegal what is Oh Holly would you sign
a waiver they live in Iowa we can knock
you out yeah by the time I made that
request way before we got to LA that
that we were to work better the movie is
Chuck it's in select cities today
nationwide next right there's Oscar buzz
here oh I know I don't even know like I
don't know what that means - it just
makes me giggle like a little bit but
but Oscar buzz in May yeah I don't know
what that means yeah when are the Oscars
again have you gone to the Oscars yeah
we want an Oscar for spotlight I say
weird welcome but I didn't did you went
in that movie uh do you get a trophy I
got to hold it I was on stage yeah we
lay down on the floor of the stage we
were so but you don't get one know his
best picture oh yeah well shouldn't
everybody get best yet like absolutely
right no were you there for lala land oh
yeah
was I there was I there no I was bitter
but I remember watching it thinking I
was there what did you what did you
think when you saw them I was always
worried about Warren Beatty then he was
gonna get blamed well I was worried
about both of them that they were gonna
get blamed for that and I felt bad
because he was trying to people thought
he was joking by stalling like okay we
know who's going to win here and then he
was sort of playing he made a face right
before you handed her over to her no
some bad time yes and they're never
gonna let people over for tea do this
that that made me I made me feel bad
have you presented yes I have how'd you
do I did okay you know what they usually
do is they put me with a very attractive
woman hmm
and I find that that helps because you
can just you know what he's noticing
your men are set you know men are in
that situation men are accessories you
know they're like we're like handbag
that's that's like that's why tuxedos
all look alike it's where we're just
there to adorn so nobody asked you who
you're wearing when you walk the red
carpet well sure they do but that's do
you answer them I do yeah huh well
otherwise I don't get it but you're free
[Laughter]
the movie is in select cities today it's
Chuck and of course the great show Ray
Donovan and voicing over hard knocks on
HBO easily obscure thank you for joining
us great system the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience